[Music]
hi this is arpan
and this is about my youtube journey i
live in mumbai india they call it city
of dreams
i came here at 2016 to fulfill my dream
i work here as a full-time grad student
at tata institute of fundamental
research
beside my studies i thought of sharing
my knowledge
with the bigger audience and that was
the genesis of my channel
i started with a phone
and a stick and recorded my handwritten
tutorials in format of a video
but there were lot of problems
nobody was watching my video and my
setup was super flimsy it always fell
down
these days i have a better setup
better recording system and a better
computer
to upgrade my graphics
i use powerpoint
adobe suit to create these graphics
all these videos you see get through a
stringent process
i study a lot to make the content i make
sure the content is really upgraded and
then i make my notes in the ipad
now balancing this with my work is
really difficult
but sometimes whenever i see your
enlightening comments
that really motivates me
let me tell you making these animation
is not at all easy
i have to work a lot and long hours to
create these animations
i have to create the scenes in the
powerpoint or after effects and then i
have to create them and put them
together as a format of animation
and that's what you see in my videos
that's what makes it attractive
so show some support using these super
tanks option your small contribution
means a lot for me
you can pay via upi
paypal or even internet banking
so show some support
and without your support i'm nothing